5 13 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about hope for the future
as high schoolers do some deep diving
into the bedrock of our democracy
the constitution of the united states
have you heard about this really cool
program called we the people it's where
highly motivated students learn the
nooks and crannies of our forefathers
famous document as well as numerous
court cases for a competition judged in
many cases by actual judges like nevada
supreme court justice alyssa kadish with
encouraging words for the sharp young
men and women like these students from
west tech the west career and technical
academy you're going out into the world
with these skills to be an important
part of our society an educated adult
who's able to have
civil conversations
based on facts and evidence
with thanks also from first district
congresswoman dina titus fourth district
congressman stephen horsford
the students have prepared responses to
questions like how and why has
presidential power expanded since the
ratification of the constitution sing in
president
powers
since the ratification of the
constitution presidential powers have
expanded then they'll be impromptu
questions is our system really working
is it a check on the president with the
students judged on their ability to
respond quickly factually and in a
civilized manner
so seven local schools six from northern
nevada taking part in this virtual we
the people tomorrow now congratulations
in advance to whichever teams are judged
to be the best but there's no question
that what justice cater said is true all
of these students are winners because
they've learned the important skills
that can only help our country move
forward from this time of division
and rancor now if you know something
that's cool at school please let us know
cool at school under the community tab
on our website eight newsnow dot com or
just send us an email cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com
really cool kids who are up on what's
happening and care about the future
and i love it i loved what she said
about you know this is a way to teach
our kids how to have informed
civil conversations
about important topics
especially at a young age i feel like
when you're comfortable whether it's
with you know how government works how
it interacts how you're supposed to
interact with other people early on you
feel comfortable with it and it feels
natural as you become older and you
actually have that in the real world
it'd be great to have conversations
instead of shouting matches civil
discourse
go we the people so we'll find out the
results tomorrow and we'll tell you
which schools are moving on but they're
all they're all winners yeah